today is the day that Ron DeSantis
launches his presidential campaign
entering the Republican primary against
the presumed and actual it's funny
presumed he's really the front runner
Donald Trump and we will soon start to
learn is there some viable path for Ron
DeSantis to the Republican nomination
the details are fascinating and abortive
Ron DeSantis is going to be launching
his campaign on Twitter uh I know in a
Twitter spaces event with Twitter owner
Elon Musk NBC news reports the Florida
governor will announce he is running for
president on Twitter Wednesday evening
in a conversation with Elon Musk we will
be streaming this Live on YouTube twitch
and Facebook I hope you will join us for
that
um NBC News explains musk and DeSantis
will host an event on Twitter spaces the
site's platform for audio Chats on
Wednesday at six Eastern it will be
moderated by David sacks a tech
entrepreneur who's a musk Confidant and
DeSantis supporter that same evening
meaning tonight the campaign will
release a launch video DeSantis will
begin visiting several early States
after Memorial Day the relationship
could could is doing a lot of work here
the relationship could be a significant
boost for DeSantis by giving him an
introduction to and credibility with
musk's massive following including his
140 million Twitter followers but it
could prove a burden should DeSantis
become distracted by the tycoon's many
controversial comments not only that I
mean listen let's be honest Ron
desantis's entire anti-woke thing is not
actually uh very much in line with Elon
Musk Tesla electric vehicles we're we're
not gonna go woke with these electric
vehicles you can't even drive right I
mean it doesn't actually make any sense
but also musk has started to
play koi with Republican elected
officials becoming buddy buddy with Greg
Abbott in Texas Etc so it's going to be
quite a wild event and I'm as curious as
anybody else you know one of the things
that we have to understand Twitter space
is why my understanding is there will be
absolutely no pushback or actual
journalistic questions asked on Twitter
spaces tonight and that may be by Design
it's not clear DeSantis wants to answer
questions tonight including the most
obvious and basic question which is what
is desantis's mathematical path to this
nomination because if we look at current
polling here's the real clear politics
averages in the 2024 Republican
Presidential nomination what you see
here the two most important lines on
this chart
are the purple line at the top which
keeps going up that's Donald Trump and
the green line down the middle which
keeps going down that's DeSantis and
DeSantis continues to see small declines
in polling now down to just 19.4 today
Trump's lead over DeSantis in the
primary is
I think as big as it has ever been I
mean at one point it reached what looks
like 32. yet Trump is now leading
DeSantis by 37 in the primary
that's that this is arguably the worst
it has looked for DeSantis since his
name started to be thrown around
seriously back in September and so the
question is how can DeSantis scoop up
all of the non-trump vote which would
get him to 44 43-44
and then if and when he does that how
does he take
at least six or seven points from Trump
to get even with him I don't know the
answer you know when we ask the question
generically right how does a candidate
take supporters from another candidate
uh there's a few ways one is you explain
DeSantis could explain his values in a
way that would appeal to the moral
beliefs of trump supporters like he
could frame his policies on immigration
or health care or education or whatever
he could frame it in terms of individual
Freedom or national security or being
anti-woke or whatever he thinks will
appeal to Maga people it doesn't really
sound likely it doesn't sound to me that
Maga voters are there waiting for
someone else to appeal to them on the
moral values that attracted them to
Trump just doesn't seem to really make
sense second possibility to take support
from a candidate that already has
support would be can you gather up
enough endorsements
from influential enough figures that
Trump supporters trust and respect that
they say hey you know what it's less
about Trump and DeSantis it's the people
that I see endorsing DeSantis makes me
makes me think I should leave Trump and
go to descendas it again doesn't seem
likely because we just looked at this
story more than 100 former Trump
officials are supporting DeSantis we've
seen a number of prominent Republicans
say we need a different direction than
Trump Maga genuinely doesn't seem to
care so that doesn't seem like a path
for DeSantis to take support from Trump
and then the third way you can take
support away from someone who has it is
you make a mathematical case you make an
empirical case you make a polling case
and you say I am the person that is best
positioned to beat Joe Biden you
convince Maga people with Trump you lose
to Biden with me you win
I honestly don't even know that that
would convince Mega voters even if it's
true because on Friday in the Friday
feedback segment we're going to look at
emails from Trump called this who say I
don't care about anything I will only
vote for Trump and that's it and so that
also doesn't seem to be a convincing
argument that DeSantis could make to
take support for Trump and again
remember the reason this matters is
Trump's already polling 56. so to win
DeSantis has to take supporters from
Trump I don't know how he does it so
we're going to look at the event tonight
we'll see what happens should be
interesting we'll see what role Elon
Musk plans to play in the DeSantis
campaign more broadly uh it seems as
though with musk behind him
Twitter is going to be potentially a
strong force supporting DeSantis but
would that be enough would that make a
difference we will see in the meantime
Trump brown-nosers and suck ups are
starting to do the dirty work for Trump
in attacking Ron DeSantis one of those
people is Carrie Lake let's talk about
that next I've had such trouble finding
a great razor where I am not cutting
myself for getting those Nicks on my
skin which are so common with the cheap
disposable razors you have to meet our
sponsor Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below